[Music]
Greta is a 16-year girl who has inspired
thousands maybe even millions of people
to send up a rope themselves in the
climate she thought everything was going
in the wrong direction and now she's
become a really big role model for a lot
of people I look up to her a lot because
I think it's so cool that she's doing
it's time that we actually stood up
through the time and did something
instead of just sitting around the
client crisis is the biggest crisis
humanity has ever faced and yet it has
been ignored for decades the older
people usually say that we owe it to the
young people to give them hope but we
don't want you to be hopeful we want you
to panic
they say that they love their children
are Ivana's and yet they are stealing
their future in front of their very eyes
[Music]
the leaders should know that change is
coming whether they like it or not
[Music]
one in four Americans is skeptical of
all the effects of climate change and
thinks this issues been exaggerated
environmental annihilation is coming
because we've been evil you know what
this is it's a snowball some people
don't believe the climate crisis they
don't understand that it's real and I I
have to say that I understand them in a
way because in the beginning when I
first found out about this I doubt that
that it was true because if it was true
then we wouldn't be talking about
anything else that would be our first
priority but it's not people say it's
like an abstract threat in the future
but it's happening now we can already
see the changes we already have
increased the temperature above
pre-industrial levels 1.2 degrees and
everything is happening very fast now we
need to do something and act as if we
were in a crisis because otherwise
people won't understand that we are in a
crisis Rita thanks to be with us hi you
said many times I was like an invisible
girl before now you are very famous
everybody's here with you and they want
you for the Nobel Prize how
this boy in August last year I decided
that this was enough I set myself down
on the ground outside the Swedish
parliament and I school straight for the
climate I have said that I will continue
to school strike every Friday until
Sweden is in line with Paris agreements
that may take a long time I will have to
be patient and to remind myself of why
I'm doing this the symbolism of the
school strike is that since you adults
don't give a damn about my future I
won't either
why should we care for our future when
we might not have one and why should we
bother to learn facts when facts don't
matter in this society it's absurd that
young people will have to skip school
and risk their own education because
they are scared of not having a future
and I think that is a very strong
message you have heard about a greater
tumour greater Thornburg Greta ten
Berghe garita tuned by Greta timber
thank you very much for joining us this
morning at first I was all alone and
then people started joining me and then
it started spreading to different places
and in different countries and then
different continents and then it became
global in December the UN had a Climate
Change Conference and there I I held
some speech as excuses and we are
running out of time I think that was
also when more people started to found
out about the school strikes and then at
the end of January I was invited to the
World Economic Forum our house is on
fire and also there I held a speech
which also went I think by room and
those two are they both those two were
tipping points on this move
it has just escalated and it's going so
fast I I can't even keep up with it
anymore now there is hundreds of
thousands of children who are striking
and hearing for their future when I was
11 I became very depressed I stopped
eating and I stopped talking and I
stopped going to school it had a lot to
do with the climate and the environment
I started making changes in my own life
like stop flying stop eating meat and
dairy and stop buying new things in
order to be able to look myself in the
eye I need to to do something myself I
started talking with my parents after
why they decided to do that as well
[Music]
before I started the school strike I was
that person who who was invisible I
never spoke unless I had to and also I
have Asperger syndrome I'm a bit
different from everyone else when you
have Asperger's you also tend to have a
capacity of being very focused and
interested in some subjects and that
allowed me to to focus on one thing for
a very long time I think that if I
wouldn't have had asparagus I don't
think I would have started the school
strike and I don't think I would have
been interested in the climbers at all
because if I would have been like
everyone else I just continued like
before not thinking twice about this and
but now I I can't do that my conscience
doesn't allow me to do that
[Music]
[Music]
I think this movement could become very
big and I think that we have just seen
the beginning because more and more
people are going to start realize the
emergency of the situation and they will
they will get angry and they will want
to do something about it especially
young people who will understand
eventually that their future is being
taken from them many people say that we
are too young to do this we shouldn't do
this and I agree we shouldn't have to do
this but the situation we are in now we
feel like we have to do this because we
won't accept you risking our future if
the adults won't take responsibility
then we will have to
you